it now let's take a look at the second implication this time we start with the Choy representation of a mapping which
we assume satis the two requirements and our goal is to come up with a cross representation for this mapping that
satisfies the requirement that we talked about earlier this implication is quite mechanical in a sense we'll need a
little bit of linear algebra and it'll mainly come down to manipulating matricies and vectors in a pretty clever
way it starts with the assumption that the Choy representation is positive semi-definite which is the first of the two requirements that we're assuming are
in place the notion of a positive semi-definite Matrix is fundamentally important in Quantum information and not just in the context of density
matrices it's absolutely critical here we wouldn't be able to make this work without it in particular the assumption
that jfi is positive semi-definite allows us to express it in the form shown on the screen for some choice of
vectors s0 through S N minus one and some choice of a positive integer n and let me note explicitly that these are
not necessarily unit vectors one way that we can get our hands on an Expression like this is from the spectral the theorem for positive
semi-definite matrices which was discussed in the previous lesson here we don't see any IG values appearing explicitly like we had in a spectral
decomposition but remember that the IG values of positive semi- different matrices are always non- negative real numbers and also keep in mind that we're
not requiring these vectors S 0 through S N minus one to be unit vectors so what we can do is to take the square roots of
the igen values and multiply them into the unit igen vectors we get from a spectrally comp position to get these
vectors s0 through S N minus1 it's actually not important for this proof that these vectors are orthogonal we do
get that from a spectral decomposition but we're not going to use that here and if we had some different expression of jfi like this that didn't come from the
spectral theorem then that would be just fine we now decompose each of these vectors as is shown on the screen and
this is just like we would do if these vectors were Quantum State vectors of a pair of systems XY and and we were
performing a standard basis measurement on the X system to be clear we're not measuring anything here we're just writing these vectors in this form which
is always possible and now here comes the trick we Define cruss matrices a0 through a n minus one by plucking the K
A's off of the front of these vectors s0 through S N minus one flipping them around so they become bra A's rather
than K A's and sticking them out to the right hand side as is shown in the equation on the screen one way to think
about this is that we're basically folding up these vectors to form matrices so that if we stacked The Columns of AK on top of one another we'd
get back s so these matrices have exactly the same entries as the corresponding vectors but we've just
rearranged the entries differently so that we get matrices but we can also think about these metrices purely symbolically in terms of direct notation
as is written here and now at this point there's an obvious question why should this work well let's not dwell too much
on why it works let's just verify that it does to do this let's define a new mapping which is the mapping defined by
these matrices where we're treating them as cross matrices what we can now do is to compute the Choy representation of
this new mapping and we'll see that it's equal to the Choy representation of the mapping F that we started with and
because Choy representations are faithful this means that the two mappings are in fact equal I won't go through the algebra in this video you
can verify that yourself it's quite mechanical and it's good practice and everything you need for that is right
here on the screen we haven't said anything yet about the two second conditions in the two boxes but they
turn out to be equivalent and one way to establish that is to verify the equation displayed here on the bottom of the
screen the letter T here by the way refers to Matrix transposition which you can alternatively think about as the
linear mapping that turns k a bra B into k b bra a and it's just something that's needed to make the formula work so in
summary there's definitely some algebra needed for this implication but like I said it's all pretty mechanical
basically index gymnastics as some people refer to this sort of thing but if you work through it and you give your brain a chance to digest it you may find
that you come away with a better understanding of how Choy representations and cross representations relate the third implication allows us
to go from a cross representation of a mapping fi where the usual condition is in place to a Stein spring representation this one is pretty
similar in spirit to the previous implication in the sense that it's mechanical and it can be viewed and verified in purely algebraic terms the
idea is actually pretty simple what we can do is to take our cross matrices and form part of a larger matrix by stacking
them on top of one another like is shown on the screen once it's filled out this will give us the unitary Matrix U for a
Stein spring representation unitary matrices have to be square matrices so we'll have to fill out as many remaining
columns as we need to do that but it won't actually make any difference what they are as long as we get a unitary
Matrix if we momentarily put aside the concern that U is unitary and just focus on the linear mapping that's defined by
the Stein spring representation we get from this Matrix U then what we find is that the mapping is equal to the
original mapping fi defined by the cross representation that we started with that's another part of the proof that I won't go through in this video you can
find the details in the written content for this lesson but you may alternatively wish to take some time and work through it for yourself just keep
in mind as usual for the series that we're using kets ordering convention to interpret the diagram so w and G will
correspond to the tensor factors on the left hand side in the equations and by the way if you do go
through it you'll find that because we have k0o bra zero as the tensor Factor on the left hand side in the equation
that we need to verify the only portion of U that has any relevance is the part given by the CR maty so as long as we
fill out the columns of you in a way that makes it unitary then we're good but of course this requires that the columns formed by a0 through a n minus
one when we stack them on top of one another are orthonormal and this is where the condition that we place on Cross representations comes into play
and indeed it's precisely equivalent to the columns being orthonormal the relevant mathematical relationships needed to draw this
conclusion are shown down here on the bottom of the screen so go ahead and pause and verify if you Choose Or again
consult the written content for further details in short what's going on here in both this implication and in the
previous one is that we're describing the same mathematical operations in different but equivalent ways the
Beating Heart for all of it essentially is matrix multiplication the fourth and final implication establishes that if we have
a Stein spring representation for some mapping then that mapping must in fact be a valid Channel and as I indicated
earlier we we already covered this implication when we discussed Stein spring representations in summary and in